This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's this idea in city planning called informal urbanism. Some people call it do it yourself urbanism. Basically informal urbanism covers all the ways people try to change their community that isn't through city planning or some kind of official process. And if you think about it, this probably happens a lot where you live. If you put up a homemade sign warning people not to sit on a broken bench or that a parking meter isn't working, that's DIY urbanism. If you put out a set of cones or a chair to reserve yourself your own personal parking spot on a public street, you are a bad person.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。城市规划中有一个概念叫“非正式城市主义”。有些人称之为“自己动手城市主义”（DIY城市主义）。基本上，非正式城市主义涵盖了人们试图改变社区的所有方式，而非通过城市规划或某种官方程序。如果你仔细想想，这在你居住的地方可能经常发生。如果你竖起一个自制的告示牌，警告人们不要坐在破损的长椅上，或者提醒人们停车计时器坏了，那就是DIY城市主义。如果你在公共街道上放上一组路锥或一把椅子，为自己预留一个私人停车位，那你就是个糟糕的人。
But that is also DIY urbanism. Gordon Douglas has written a whole book about this idea. It's called The Help Yourself City. It looks at all the ways people are taking matters into their own hands, both for good reasons and for incredibly selfish ones. He's local to Oakland, so he came in here to the 99Pi HQ, and we had a great conversation all about the joy and chaos of DIY urbanism. And we started out by talking about one of the most perfect examples of the good kind of DIY urbanism.
但这同样也是DIY城市主义。戈登·道格拉斯写了一整本关于这个概念的书，书名叫《自助城市》。它审视了人们将事情掌握在自己手中的各种方式，既有出于好意的，也有出于极其自私动机的。他是奥克兰本地人，所以他来到了99Pi总部，我们进行了一场关于DIY城市主义的乐趣与混乱的精彩对话。我们首先谈论的是DIY城市主义中那种最完美的例子之一。
A municipal failure that led to a DIY intervention and then to real permanent change. The Hellgate Bridge in Queens, New York. Well, so the Hellgate Bridge is this kind of enormous feat of engineering that was built to be one of these single strongest sort of structures in the known world at the time that it was built. I read once if all human life ceased to exist, it would still stand for some hundreds and hundreds of years with no maintenance whatsoever. The Hellgate Bridge is also a big kind of clunky old piece of infrastructure.
一个导致了DIY干预，并最终带来真正永久性改变的市政失败案例。纽约皇后区的地狱门大桥。嗯，地狱门大桥是那种巨大的工程壮举，在建造时被认为是当时已知世界上最坚固的结构之一。我曾经读到过，如果人类生命全部消失，它依然能屹立几百年，无需任何维护。地狱门大桥也是一种笨重的大型旧基础设施。
It's a railroad bridge. It had started to leak and crack and have little maintenance issues. Not the sort that we're going to cause any danger to anybody, but it was leaking all over the place down under its viaducts where normal New Yorkers were going about their days in Queens walking under these old archways. And in particular, a lot of folks in this part of Astoria noticed that there was this kind of scum they called it, a some sort of effluence kind of coming down out of the leak in the bridge.
这是一座铁路桥。它开始出现渗漏和裂缝，并有一些小的维护问题。虽然不是那种会给任何人造成危险的问题，但它一直在高架桥下到处渗漏，而普通的纽约人在皇后区走在这些古老的拱门下过着他们的日常生活。特别是，阿斯托里亚这一带的许多人注意到，有一种他们称之为“浮渣”的东西，某种污水从桥上的裂缝中流下来。
That was probably just kind of rainwater runoff, trickling through a century of steel and other sort of stuff. And rust and right made it kind of nasty. And it was gross and it was running across the sidewalk. And so when it froze, it was super dangerous and slippery. And when it was warm out, it was just gross and green and kind of slimy. A handful of neighborhood folks got together with a couple other people and basically built a small bridge to go over this effluence. So it's a tiny bridge underneath the gigantic bridge.
那可能只是一种雨水径流，流经了一个世纪的钢铁和其他杂物。铁锈让它变得很恶心。它很脏，流过人行道。所以当它结冰时，非常危险且湿滑。而天气暖和时，它就变得又脏又绿，黏糊糊的。一小群邻居和另外几个人聚在一起，基本上建了一座小桥来跨过这些污水。所以这是一座位于巨大桥梁下方的小桥。
Exactly. Just so pedestrians can walk over this river of scum that comes off of the bridge. That's right. Which they call the Astoria scum river bridge. And like, how why do we talking about this? The bridge of the scum river. I think it probably varies, but in, I think an athletic person could leap over it.
没错。只是为了让行人能走过那条从桥上流下来的污水河。没错。他们称之为“阿斯托里亚污水河大桥”。那么，我们为什么要谈论这个？污水河大桥。我想这可能因人而异，但我觉得一个运动能力强的人应该能跳过去。
Yeah. And so why wasn't the city handling the scum river? Like, who was responsible for the scum river? Well, so there was a bit of, as is often the case with this kind of stuff, there's a bit of a lack of clarity in terms of who's responsible, right? Because some railroad company built this thing, right, along with the early public works, folks of New York City and all that, and then that street down there is the problem of the New York City Department of Transportation, right? So street down there is the problem of the New York City Department
是的。那么为什么市政部门不处理这条污水河呢？谁该为这条污水河负责？嗯，正如这类事情经常发生的那样，在谁该负责的问题上有点不明确，对吧？因为是某家铁路公司建造了这个东西，对吧，连同纽约市早期的公共工程人员等等，然后下面的那条街道是纽约市交通局的问题，对吧？所以下面的街道是纽约市交通局的问题
of Transportation, right? So I think there was no clear answer. I also don't think that it was clear even who you might begin to complain about something like a leaky bridge too, and it caught a little bit of attention. It was actually very quickly responded to by the local councilman who wrote a letter like thanking them for their good citizenship. And you know, in fact, it was repaired quite quickly and has ceased to be an issue and the DIY bridge was dismantled. Right. And so this, this so embarrassed amtrak that they decided that they were going to fix it and they did.
对吧？所以我认为没有明确的答案。我也不认为清楚你应该向谁投诉像漏水桥梁这样的事情，它引起了一点关注。当地议员很快就做出了回应，他写了一封信感谢他们的良好公民意识。而且，事实上，它很快就得到了修复，不再是一个问题，那座DIY桥也被拆除了。没错。这让美国铁路公司感到非常尴尬，以至于他们决定要修复它，他们也确实这么做了。
Whatever repairs, which were probably minor, you know, that were needed, were made. The city council was pleased to have affected some change and made some people's lives better. And then they dismantled a bridge and then Jason and poster child and the other kind of folks who had done it dismantled it. Yeah, so you call these kind of interventions informal urbanism, but for informal urbanism to exist we have to talk about the rise of kind of urbanism in general. So how new is the concept of urban planning in an urbanism context? You know, it's really hard to put a pinn a date on some of this stuff, but we know that planning as a sort of professional vocation
无论需要什么维修（可能很小），都完成了。市议会很高兴能促成一些改变，让一些人的生活变得更好。然后他们拆除了桥，杰森和海报上的孩子以及其他做这件事的人拆除了它。是的，你把这种干预称为非正式城市主义，但为了让非正式城市主义存在，我们必须谈谈城市主义整体的兴起。那么，在城市主义背景下，城市规划这个概念有多新呢？你知道，给这些东西定个日期真的很难，但我们知道，作为一种职业的规划
and comes around along with a whole bunch of other professions in 18th and 19th centuries as cities kind of become more organized and science in general becomes more kind of rationalized, right? And you could look at ancient Rome and find analogs, and certainly there were aspects of planning always. But the idea that we might have a professional planner goes back to sort of 17th and 18th centuries as we started to deal with kind of chaotic cities. And the way that the planning profession understands itself is even more recent. As a reaction to the sort of chaos of the late 19th century city, the, you know, the London of Dickens, right, these massive, complicated, in many ways, terrible places, right, where there was a great deal of inequality and a great deal of suffering. So planning as a profession, especially in
是在18、19世纪随着其他一大堆职业一起出现的，当时城市变得更加有组织，科学总体上也变得更加理性化，对吧？你可以看看古罗马并找到类似的例子，当然规划的某些方面一直存在。但我们可能拥有专业规划师的想法可以追溯到17、18世纪，当时我们开始处理混乱的城市。而规划行业对自身的理解则更近。作为对19世纪末城市混乱的一种反应，你知道，狄更斯笔下的伦敦，对吧，这些巨大、复杂、在许多方面都很糟糕的地方，对吧，那里存在着巨大的不平等和巨大的苦难。所以作为一种职业的规划，特别是在
the American context, emerges as a kind of response to social problems in the city and the idea that we can kind of rationalize this. And so then you have it becoming increasingly professionalized. You have the first sort of programs to train urban planners in the early 20th century, first official programs in urban design, as recently as like the 50s and 60s. And so while the city has always been this organic, complicated, human-made project, I think it does become increasingly professionalized in the 19th and 20th centuries. The idea, especially in the global North,
美国背景下，作为对城市社会问题的一种回应而出现，并认为我们可以将其理性化。于是它变得越来越专业化。你在20世纪初有了第一批培养城市规划师的项目，而第一批城市设计的官方项目直到50和60年代才出现。因此，虽然城市一直是一个有机的、复杂的、人造的项目，但我认为它在19和20世纪确实变得越来越专业化。这种想法，特别是在全球北方，
especially in North America, it became kind of increasingly surprising that somebody might take something like this into their own hands, because it had become such somebody else's job. Do these interventions happen because there's a lack of planning or because there's bad planning or what brings this on? People are out there living their lives in real public spaces, real urban spaces in ways
特别是在北美，有人可能会把这样的事情掌握在自己手中变得越来越令人惊讶，因为它已经变成了别人的工作。这些干预是因为缺乏规划，还是因为规划糟糕，或者是什么导致了这种情况？人们在真实的公共空间、真实的城市空间中生活，其方式
that a city planning department can't hope to, even if everybody lives in town, right? They don't walk the same streets the same way everybody does. They don't think about whether this curb is a little too high for a kid on a bike to get up, you know? It's a complex system. So it's like, you can't really fault someone for not knowing every permutation of a complex system. Right. Yeah.
是城市规划部门无法企及的，即使每个人都住在城里，对吧？他们不会像每个人那样走同样的街道。他们不会考虑这个路缘石对于骑自行车的孩子来说是不是太高了，你知道吗？这是一个复杂的系统。所以，你真的不能因为某人不知道复杂系统的每一个排列组合而责怪他们。没错。是的。
No, totally. And I mean, the vast majority of this sort of infrastructure and stuff that planners work really hard to get built, including quite progressive pieces of, you know, bicycle facilities and things like that are wonderful and can't get done by me and my neighbor and a shovel, right? But, but there's also stuff that people notice. I mean, one of the things I mentioned kind of quickly is there's a street in Brooklyn near where I used to live where trucks were constantly parking on the sidewalk. In fact, that happens all over Brooklyn. It happens all over many cities. But if you're in a narrow street and you are making a delivery, you might think like actually the best move for me here is going to be to pull up onto this sidewalk to unload all
不，完全同意。我的意思是，绝大多数这类基础设施和规划者努力建造的东西，包括相当进步的自行车设施之类的，都是很棒的，而且不是我和我的邻居拿着铲子就能完成的，对吧？但也有人们注意到的事情。我的意思是，我刚才快速提到的事情之一是，在我以前住的布鲁克林附近有一条街，卡车经常停在人行道上。事实上，这在布鲁克林到处都在发生。它在许多城市都发生。但如果你在一条狭窄的街道上送货，你可能会想，对我来说最好的做法是开上人行道来卸下我所有的
my crap and not block the street anymore. But it was damaging the sidewalk and ball bothering pedestrians and whenever and so somebody who I eventually tracked down worked in one of the local stores there, I had just made a sign that looked as professional as you can do with paint, you know, with your own materials that just said no parking on the sidewalk. Right. And it looked exactly like the one the city would put up if it were, except for that it wasn't on vinyl and it was like, you know,
垃圾，不再堵塞街道。但这损坏了人行道，打扰了行人，所以有人（我最终找到了他，他在当地一家商店工作）制作了一个标志，看起来尽可能专业（用你自己的材料和油漆），上面只写着“禁止在人行道停车”。没错。它看起来和城市如果安装的话会放的标志一模一样，除了它不是乙烯基材质的，而且它是，你知道，
it was just on cardboard or something like that. But they weren't trying to do anything cute. Yeah. It was just an effort to stop people from parking on the sidewalk. Yeah. And I see tons of that stuff. And it does get cute sometimes where they'll put, you know, DIY instead of the
它只是写在纸板之类的东西上。但他们并不是想搞什么花样。是的。这只是为了阻止人们在人行道上停车。是的。我看到了很多这样的东西。而且它有时确实会变得很可爱，他们会放上，你知道，DIY而不是
D-O-T for a department of transportation. That was what some of these folks in Los Angeles who were painting their own bike lanes were doing. And so who are the people generally carrying out these kinds of interventions? I think that anybody living in a neighborhood has maybe some moments where they feel like, oh, I could fix that. Or maybe I should fix that. And I don't want to, I'm always careful to sort of remind people I'm speaking to that we clean our streets ourselves, right?
DOT（交通局）。这就是洛杉矶那些自己粉刷自行车道的人所做的。那么，通常是谁在进行这些干预呢？我认为任何住在社区里的人可能都有一些时刻觉得，哦，我可以修复那个。或者也许我应该修复那个。我总是小心地提醒我交谈的人，我们自己清理街道，对吧？
We sweep out front of our business if we're a business owner or we at least are supposed to keep up a sidewalk and do that kind of stuff. People put up signs in their neighborhoods about locks cats and people do tons of things to make their neighborhoods themselves. They also write graffiti all over the place, create roadside memorials, and do all sorts of things like that.
如果我们是企业主，我们会清扫店门前，或者我们至少应该维护人行道并做这类事情。人们在社区里张贴关于丢失猫的告示，人们为了让社区变得更好做了很多事情。他们还在到处乱涂乱画，建立路边纪念碑，并做各种各样类似的事情。
And I think that that stuff is just widespread across all cultures and classes and whatever. But I did find that most of the people creating the sort of visible do-it-yourself urban design interventions, those that really seem to be reflecting urban planning ideals and the sort of things that the city might really should be doing. City might not agree that they should be doing it, but people view it as the sort of thing a city could do. Even if you can tell in one glance that the city had nothing to do with it,
我认为这些东西在所有文化和阶层中都很普遍。但我确实发现，大多数创造这种可见的DIY城市设计干预措施的人，那些似乎真的反映了城市规划理想以及城市可能真的应该做的事情（城市可能不同意他们应该这样做，但人们认为这是城市可以做的事情）。即使你一眼就能看出城市与此无关，
because it looks so scrappy, it's trying to kind of do that. Trying to make a statement, it's existence is making a statement. Sure, yeah. The more and more people I talk to who we're doing this, once you get beyond people who are maybe just kind of
因为它看起来很粗糙，它是在试图做点什么。试图发表声明，它的存在本身就是在发表声明。当然，是的。我交谈过的人越来越多，一旦你超越了那些可能只是在
repairing a pothole in their front yard or something like that, I found that the vast majority of people doing this looked like me. They were predominantly white, they were predominantly male, and a lot of them had backgrounds in design and planning and or at least some sort of professional education. And the additional point that I would make here is that a lot of them as a result of all that
自家前院修补坑洼之类的人，我发现绝大多数做这件事的人看起来都像我。他们主要是白人，主要是男性，而且他们中的许多人有设计和规划背景，或者至少受过某种专业教育。我在这里要补充的一点是，他们中的许多人因为所有这些
and other things had quite a bit of privilege that they were kind of aware that they had, that I think whether they were thinking about it explicitly or not makes it a heck of a lot easier to go out and feel comfortable at three in the morning, painting a bike lane down a street or climbing a light post to hang up a sign, let alone impersonating a public works employee with an orange vest and wearing a hat and doing all this kind of stuff
以及其他事情，拥有相当多的特权，他们对此有所察觉。我认为无论他们是否明确考虑过这一点，这都让他们在凌晨三点出门，在街上粉刷自行车道，或者爬上灯柱挂标志，更不用说穿着橙色背心、戴着帽子冒充公共工程员工，做所有这些事情变得容易得多，
that many of the folks I interviewed did. Once you hit that level of active DIY urbanism practice on the streets, they were overwhelmingly wonderfully intelligent and well-meaning, but very privileged and somewhat hubristic. Yeah, folks. You could interpret that two ways. One is, is that you could go. This represents a type of privilege that people should be mindful of, you know, the hubris that you mentioned. But also, I think it's incumbent on people with privilege to take action when that's what privileges should be for, rather than just resting and
我采访的许多人都这么做过。一旦你达到了那种在街头进行积极DIY城市主义实践的水平，他们绝大多数都非常聪明且善意，但非常特权且有些傲慢。是的，伙计们。你可以有两种解读。一种是，这代表了一种人们应该注意的特权，你知道，你提到的傲慢。但同时，我认为拥有特权的人有责任在特权应该发挥作用时采取行动，而不是仅仅休息和
profiting, you know, and so you could take that as the alternative. You know, for the most part, when we tell these stories of tactical urbanism and formal urbanism, they're fun and they kind of have a quality of being sort of just good, unalloyed good, you know, fixing the scum river problem is this is great. But interventions can have sort of a salt system and selfishness to them. Could you tell me about the bus stop in Seattle? I'm not sure. Yeah. So that's a great example of somebody who was, in a sense, while meaning, the story is that this man I know was living in Seattle and had begun to notice
获利，你知道，所以你可以将其视为另一种选择。你知道，在大多数情况下，当我们讲述这些战术城市主义和非正式城市主义的故事时，它们很有趣，而且有一种纯粹的好东西的特质，你知道，解决污水河问题这太棒了。但干预措施可能带有某种盐分和自私。你能告诉我西雅图那个公交车站的事吗？我不确定。是的。这是一个很好的例子，有人在某种意义上是善意的，故事是这样的：我认识的这个人住在西雅图，开始注意到
that trash was piling up at the bus stop outside near his house. And he was frustrated by all this garbage and constantly feeling like he had to clean it up or walk over it and he realized that the city had failed to provide a trash can at the city provided bus stop. So he's emailing the city and calling the city, but after months and months of hearing nothing
垃圾在离他家很近的公交车站堆积。他对所有这些垃圾感到沮丧，总是觉得他必须清理它或跨过它，他意识到城市没能在城市提供的公交车站提供垃圾桶。所以他给城市发邮件、打电话，但在几个月又几个月毫无音讯之后，
and realizing, to his mind, there was just no chance they were ever in a response to that, right? So he went out in the middle of the night with a bolt cutter and just cut off the bus stop and threw it in the bushes. And this is like one of these like kind of eight-foot poles that just says bus stop. Yeah, bus number whatever. It wasn't like a bench or a little shelter or anything. It's just a pole that had a bus of number, whatever. It wasn't like a bench or a little shelter or anything. It's just a pole that had a bus stop number on it.
他意识到，在他看来，他们根本不可能回应，对吧？所以他在半夜带着断线钳出去，把公交车站牌剪掉扔进了灌木丛里。这就像那种八英尺高的杆子，上面写着“公交车站”。是的，几号公交车之类的。它不像长椅或小遮阳棚什么的。它只是一个杆子，上面有一个公交车站号码。
Right. So he cut the whole pole down and threw it in the bushes. You know, he pointed out to me that for instance, there was another bus stop not too far up the road. Why wasn't it his impulse to put a trash can in there? That's a great question. So I asked him that. I said, well, why if you were going to go in this trouble? Why not? And he said, oh, I thought about that. He had a great question. So I asked him that. I said, well, why if you were going to go to
没错。所以他把整个杆子砍倒扔进了灌木丛。你知道，他向我指出，例如，路不远处还有另一个公交车站。为什么他没有冲动去那里放一个垃圾桶？这是一个很好的问题。所以我问了他。我说，好吧，如果你要费这么大劲，为什么不呢？他说，哦，我想过那个。他有一个很好的问题。所以我问了他。我说，好吧，如果你要费
this trouble? Why not? And he said, oh, I thought about that. He had a whole design. He was going to get a little like a chicken wire thing and kind of wrap it around that. Sure. But he pointed out probably quite rightly that the city would not know it was there. And nobody would come empty that garbage can out. And so he'd be still stuck. I'm seeing how this is garbage, which you know, you could argue is better than removing a bus stop. Okay, so you, so you remove the bus stop. The bus stop stopping there, which is amazing to me that the, that the bus driver is looking for those cues in the environment
这么大劲，为什么不呢？他说，哦，我想过那个。他有一个完整的设计。他打算弄一个像铁丝网一样的东西，把它包在上面。当然。但他指出，可能非常正确的是，城市不会知道它在那里。而且没人会来清空那个垃圾桶。所以他还是会被困住。我明白这怎么是垃圾，你知道，你可以说这比拆除公交车站要好。好吧，所以你，所以你拆除了公交车站。公交车不再停在那里，这让我感到惊讶，公交车司机在环境中寻找那些线索
and just to know to stop there if there is a sign there. Yeah, I mean, it's not like I don't, I don't believe they stopped immediately, but I think over time. Yeah. But then, you know, the city came immediately, but I think over time. Yeah, but then you know The city came in and put another bus stop in yeah, and he decided not to remove it I mean the kind of act which might be you know to own us and I don't want a empty city trash either yeah
如果那里有标志，就知道要在那里停车。是的，我的意思是，我不认为他们会立即停止，但我认为随着时间的推移。是的。但后来，你知道，城市立即来了，但我认为随着时间的推移。是的，但后来你知道城市进来并放了另一个公交车站，是的，他决定不拆除它。我的意思是，这种行为可能是，你知道，对我们来说，我也不想清空城市垃圾，是的。
It's to put a trash can there and then empty the trash can but that type of act strikes me as Privilege taken too far. Mm-hmm. Sure. I mean there there are also, I mean, to take a more extreme example, there are people who paint red curbs gray to create parking spaces for themselves, right? Put trash cans on top of fire hydrants to create parking spaces that appear to be legal. I spent quite a bit of time learning about these variety of Malibu home owners who've been trying to stop people from using the public access to the beach in Malibu through all sorts of stuff that is essentially the more anti-social equivalent of all the stuff we've been talking about there.
那是放一个垃圾桶在那里，然后清空垃圾桶，但那种行为让我觉得是特权走得太远了。嗯哼。当然。我的意思是，还有，我的意思是，举一个更极端的例子，有人把红色的路缘石漆成灰色，为自己创造停车位，对吧？把垃圾桶放在消防栓上，创造出看起来合法的停车位。我花了很多时间了解这些马里布房主，他们一直试图通过各种本质上是我们一直在谈论的所有事情的反社会等价物，来阻止人们使用马里布的海滩公共通道。
They're putting up gates, they're putting up signs that say private beach, they're hiring private security. But a bike lane is like you you were putting it there for the benefit of, hopefully, lots of lots of bicyclers, but blocking off a beach in Malibu or painting your own private curb is really just for yourself. Yeah, it is. I mean, some of these interventions are even more complicated in terms of just like being either selfish or selfless. I mean, another one of these I thought was really interesting was the DIY bus benches interventions are even more complicated in terms of just like being either selfish or selfless.
他们竖起大门，竖起写着“私人海滩”的标志，他们雇佣私人保安。但自行车道就像你为了很多很多骑自行车的人的利益而把它放在那里，但封锁马里布的海滩或粉刷你自己的私人路缘石真的只是为了你自己。是的，确实。我的意思是，其中一些干预措施在是自私还是无私方面甚至更复杂。我的意思是，另一个我觉得非常有趣的是DIY公交长椅，干预措施甚至更复杂，在是自私还是无私方面。
I mean, another one of these I thought was really interesting was the DIY bus benches in Los Angeles that they put there to fix the lack of public seating because a lot of the times advertisements pay for the public seating in the places that the population doesn't have as desirable to advertisers, then there's no benches. And so they put in benches, but that's complicated because it's not a matter of just putting in benches, you actually have to take care of benches.
我的意思是，另一个我觉得非常有趣的是洛杉矶的DIY公交长椅，他们把它放在那里是为了解决缺乏公共座位的问题，因为很多时候广告商为人口不那么受广告商欢迎的地方的公共座位买单，那么就没有长椅。所以他们放了长椅，但这很复杂，因为这不仅仅是放长椅的问题，你实际上必须照顾长椅。
Yeah, that's right. And so I should say, it's now the case that there are some stipulations of like where, if you're an advertising company, you have to put benches in there. But yes, huge amounts of Los Angeles are these kind of long, stark, hot boulevards where people rely heavily on the bus, and there is no shelter, no seat, no nothing.
是的，没错。所以我应该说，现在的情况是，有一些规定，比如如果你是一家广告公司，你必须在那里放长椅。但是是的，洛杉矶有大量这种漫长、荒凉、炎热的林荫大道，人们非常依赖公交车，而且没有遮阳棚，没有座位，什么都没有。
Again, all across the city, people have built these benches. They're just places to sit while you're waiting for the bus. Sometimes they're just literally a chair that somebody has hauled out there or maybe found in the trash and put there. But yeah, the problem with this, and this goes back to just how complicated all this stuff is and whether any of these things can really be purely altruistic because once you have put something out there, good old fashioned urban planners have to deal with it or good old fashioned street maintenance people have to deal with it.
同样，在整个城市，人们建造了这些长椅。它们只是你在等公交车时可以坐的地方。有时它们实际上只是某人从外面拖出来的椅子，或者可能是在垃圾里找到并放在那里的。但是是的，这个问题，这回到了所有这些东西有多复杂，以及这些事情中是否有任何一件能真正纯粹是利他主义的，因为一旦你把东西放在那里，老派的城市规划者就必须处理它，或者老派的街道维护人员就必须处理它。
I also spoke to a lot of planners for the book and they would say you know the problem with this is that somebody's gonna get a splinter in there but at some point and then it's gonna be our problem, right? Or whose problem it at the very least if it's not our problem, it's gotta be somebody because this thing is gonna slowly deteriorate over the winter and the concern would be that there's not a lot of forethought. There are people out there who also just do DIY maintenance. I talked to one guy who goes out and fixes playgrounds all over the place for no recognition whatsoever.
我也为这本书采访了很多规划者，他们会说，你知道，这个问题在于某人会在某个时候被木刺扎到，然后这就成了我们的问题，对吧？或者至少如果不是我们的问题，也必须是某人的问题，因为这个东西会在冬天慢慢腐烂，而且担心的是没有太多的预见性。还有一些人也只是做DIY维护。我和一个人谈过，他到处去修理游乐场，没有任何认可。
So maybe they could get together. But I think in the next episode. That's right. But in the meantime, that is one of those often unselibrated things that good old fashioned bureaucracy gets done, just like ideally. I mean, more in some cities than in others. But theoretically, the city is maintaining public infrastructure.
所以也许他们可以聚在一起。但我认为在下一集里。没错。但与此同时，那是那种经常被忽视的事情之一，老派的官僚机构确实完成了，就像理想情况一样。我的意思是，在某些城市比在其他城市更多。但理论上，城市正在维护公共基础设施。
Do sometimes these DIY interventions and what someone wants in the city and then another person wants in a city Come into conflict with each other So certainly I think oftentimes these things will be more reflective of one person's priority than another Which is kind of again, not that bureaucratic planning is perfect But at least it's ostensibly has a democratic process behind it, right? Right? For instance kind of my favorite example is also in Brooklyn, Bedford Avenue, right,
有时这些DIY干预措施以及一个人在城市中想要的和另一个人在城市中想要的会发生冲突吗？当然，我认为这些事情往往会比其他事情更能反映一个人的优先事项，这又回到了，并不是说官僚规划是完美的，但至少它表面上有一个民主过程在背后，对吧？对吧？例如，我最喜欢的例子也在布鲁克林，贝德福德大道，对吧，
which is one of the longest streets in New York City and had one of the longest bike lanes in New York City on it. And at a certain point, it passes through the predominantly Hasidic community in South Williamsburg. And the Sautmar Hacita didn't like all of the people biking through this neighborhood for a variety of reasons, but pretty clearly, and I think not, they didn't try to disguise this as something else, said they didn't like that there was a lot of scantly clad, young hipster types, biking through their neighborhood.
它是纽约市最长的街道之一，上面有纽约市最长的自行车道之一。在某一点上，它穿过了南威廉斯堡以哈西德派为主的社区。萨特马尔哈西德派不喜欢所有骑自行车穿过这个社区的人，原因有很多，但很明显，而且我认为不是，他们没有试图把这伪装成别的东西，说他们不喜欢有很多衣着暴露的年轻嬉皮士类型的人骑车穿过他们的社区。
And they were able to get that bike lane removed for those blocks through South Williamsburg, which of course incensed those in the more activist cycling community who threatened all sorts of things, including a naked bike ride through the neighborhood, which never actually materialized. But there was at that time a great deal of tension. This was seen as a real kind of a front to the cycling community, which I think, you know, politics aside,
他们能够通过南威廉斯堡的那些街区拆除那条自行车道，这当然激怒了那些更激进的自行车社区的人，他们威胁要进行各种事情，包括在社区里进行裸体骑行，但这从未真正实现。但在那时，存在着巨大的紧张关系。这被视为对自行车社区的一种真正的冒犯，我认为，你知道，抛开政治不谈，
it was truly a major bike route. Yeah. But it was gone and it was taken away legally due to the political pressure from the community that it went through. And so then you had some do-it-yourselfers out there in the middle of the night trying to re-stripe this by the way. Yeah, that makes sense. And they then were apprehended by the showroom, which is the I would say DIY police
它确实是一条主要的自行车路线。是的。但它消失了，并且由于它所经过的社区的政治压力而被合法地拆除了。于是，你有一些DIY者在半夜试图重新划这条线。是的，这说得通。然后他们被肖姆林（Shomrim）逮捕了，也就是我所说的哈西德社区的DIY警察
force of the Hacita community, right? Yeah, who I mean, in that community is full of DIY for lack of a better word, efforts from local signage, which I've seen just on all levels, signage about how to park properly in the neighborhood, like encouraging people to park efficiently, so there's many spaces possible I've seen that, to stuff that's more controversial, there's been articles written about signage that goes up that instructs, say, women to walk on one side of the streets and other kinds of cultural things that are happening in that community. So their own neighborhood police force actually stopped these, do it
部队，对吧？是的，那个社区充满了DIY，如果没有更好的词的话，从当地的标牌（我已经在各个层面看到了，关于如何在该社区正确停车的标牌，比如鼓励人们高效停车，以便尽可能多地腾出空间，我见过那个）到更具争议的东西，有文章写过关于张贴的标牌，指示女性走街道的一侧，以及在该社区发生的其他文化事情。所以他们自己的社区警察部队实际上阻止了这些DIY自行车道的人，并扣留了他们，直到纽约警察局赶到，人们被逮捕了。所以你确实有那种DIY对DIY的情况。据我所知，南威廉斯堡贝德福德大道上的那些街区仍然没有自行车道。戈登·道格拉斯和我谈论了DIY城市主义的增长以及城市从这场运动中吸取的教训。稍后回来。你认为为什么我们看到了
yourself by claim folks, and held them until the NYPD could come and people were arrested. And so you really did have kind of like a DIY on DIY situation. There's the best of my knowledge. There's still no bike lane through those blocks of South Williamsburg on Bedford. Gordon Douglas and I talk about the uptick and DIY urbanism and the lessons cities are taking from the movement. After this. Why is it, do you think that we've seen a kind of uptick
非正式城市主义的增长？你认为这说明了我们现在的城市方式吗？所以我认为有两件事在起作用。一是可能对城市空间变得多么专业化的一种更自然、有机的反应。人们简单地认识到，并非所有事情都能由这种非常专业化的国家规划机构处理，他们看到了他们可以修复的东西。
in informal urbanism? And do you think it says something about the way our cities are now? So I think that there are two things that play. One is perhaps a more organic natural reaction to how professionalized urban space had become. Simply people recognizing that not everything can be handled by this very professionalized state planning apparatus and they see stuff that they can fix.
与此相关的是，我认为至少在过去10年里，甚至在过去40年里，我们看到了我们城市身体健康的许多起伏，对吧？在60和70年代，当城市真的被忽视时，你有过这种时刻。那就是一些早期例子出现的时候，特别是像游击园艺这样的事情，在大量空地
Tied to that I think is at least over the last 10 years but even more so over the last kind of 40 we've seen a lot of ups and downs in the physical health of our cities, right? You have moments of this stuff in the 60s and 70s when cities were really being neglected. And that's when some of the early examples, especially things like guerrilla gardening come about, in the context of a ton of vacant lots
和大量空置的背景下。同样，在2008年住房危机和金融危机以及经济衰退中，那是我进行大量研究的时候，是在那之后。我不认为这完全是对城市没钱、无法做到这一点的反应，但这是一种广泛的趋势。即使现在，在强劲的经济中，城市也没有其他实体拥有的钱。他们必须依赖像广告公司这样的东西来建造他们的公交候车亭，对吧？我认为这把我带到了第二点，即
and a ton of vacancy. And again, in the 2008 housing crisis and financial crisis, and recession, that's when I was doing a lot of my research was kind of on the tail end of that. I don't think that it's all a reaction to like cities having no money and not being able to do it, but that is a broad trend. Even now, in a strong economy, cities don't have the money that other entities have. And they have to rely on things like advertising companies to build their bus shelters, right? And I think that brings me to the sort of second point, which is
我们生活在一个我们已经把很多这类东西去中心化，或者如果你愿意的话，新自由主义化的时代。我们很多的公共服务以及让我们的城市运行和看起来美观的基本责任。我们依赖开发商来建造公园。我们依赖开发商来资助学校什么的，因为我们不能适当地向自己征税，我们自己也没有服务。作为城市，我们没有资源来做这件事。所以这与更广泛的经济形势无关。
that we live in an era in which we have sort of decentralized a lot of this stuff, or neoliberalized, if you will. A lot of our public services and a lot of the basic responsibilities for getting our cities to run and to look nice. And we rely on a developer to build a park. And we rely on a developer to fund a school or whatever because we can't tax ourselves properly and we don't have the services ourselves. We don't have the resources to do it as cities. And so kind of doesn't matter about the broader economic situation.
我们只是处于这种新自由主义时刻。DIY者在某种程度上是完美的新自由主义行动者，对吧？很容易把他们看作是这些伟大的社区导向的草根好撒玛利亚人。但他们也只是个人，在做他们认为最好的事情，以及国家没有做的事情。所以他们把事情掌握在自己手中，这有点鼓舞人心，但也像是一个非常个人主义社会的完美例子，在这个社会中，国家什么都不做。而且他们没有任何监管，就像企业开发商一样，你知道，做
We're just in this kind of neoliberal moment. Do it yourselfers are kind of in some ways perfect neoliberal actors, right? It's easy to view them as these kind of great community-oriented grassroots good Samaritans. But they're also just individuals doing what they think is best and what the state isn't doing. And so they're taking it into their own hands, and that's kind of inspiring, but also like the perfect example of a very individualistic society in which the state is not doing anything. And they don't have any more oversight than like a corporate developer, you know, doing
一些大的，我们总是哀叹国家没有足够地监管开发之类的想法，或者至少我们这些规划界的左派是这样。然而这是一种类似的情况。它看起来小得多，但这些做这类事情的人肯定没有更多的民主监督。没错。你必须以某种方式解决，或者你必须分别评估每一个人，如果它符合你的
some big, big, and we always bemoan this idea that the state isn't regulating development enough or something like that, or at least those of us on the left in planning to. And yet this is kind of a similar situation. It looks a lot smaller, but there's certainly no more democratic oversight over any of these folks doing this kind of stuff. Right. You have to sort of address or you have to assess each individually if it conforms to your
价值观。这是一个巨大的观点。我的意思是，我认为我们确实必须分别评估这些。这就是为什么我认为这种合法性的问题比某事是正式还是非正式、合法还是非法的问题更重要，只是它是否是一个合适的契合点。这很模糊。在规划中处理这个问题非常困难，对吧？当然。
values of that type of. That's a huge point. I mean, I think we do really have to assess these individually. And that's why I think that this question of kind of legitimacy is kind of more important than the question of whether or not something is formal or informal or legal or illegal is just whether it's an appropriate fit. And that's squishy. That's very difficult to deal with in planning, right? For sure.
但当我们与人交谈时，我们可以开始弄清楚它，这就是为什么社区参与如此重要。每当我们公开地，或者，你知道，正式或非正式地重塑城市空间时。城市空间公开地，或者，你知道，正式或非正式地。你能谈谈城市规划的正式结构是如何吸取个人干预主义的教训，以不同于以往的方式创造空间的吗？比如，我觉得我注意到了这一点。过去公共广场是什么样的，它非常，就像柱子和大理石之类的。
But we can begin to figure it out when we talk to people, and that's why community participation is so, so important. And whenever we're reshaping urban space publicly or, you know, formally or informally. urban space publicly or, you know, formally or informally. Could you talk about how the formal structures of urban planning taken some of the lessons of, you know, individual interventionism to create spaces differently than they maybe used to? Like, I feel like I've noticed this. There used to be like what a public square was and it was very, it's like columns and marble and stuff.
而现在是折叠椅。你如何看待这些结果反馈到正式的城市规划社区？是的，我认为绝对是这样。这是你关于为什么我们现在看到这种增长的答案的另一部分。我认为这与有某个时刻关系不大，
And now it's folding chairs. How have you seen the results like feedback into the formalized urban planning community? Yeah, I think that's absolutely the case. And it's another part of your answer of kind of why are we seeing an uptick in this now to the extent that we are. I think it has less to do with there being some moment
而是这些策略，特别是这种DIY文化的审美，已经变得非常时髦和主流。例如，你确实有，我认为，主要是积极的城市趋势，朝着步行友好、宜居、行人公共空间、完整街道，特别是像战术城市主义这样的趋势，对吧？在每一个规模上，一直到纽约市交通局，运用战术城市主义的理想和战术城市主义的审美来改变，比如，时代广场，对吧，从一个巨大复杂的道路交叉口变成一个非常不同的行人广场。没错。
than that these tactics, and in particular, these aesthetics of kind of DIY culture, have become very trendy and mainstream. So for instance, you have really, I think, mainly positive urban trends toward walkability, livability, pedestrian public spaces, complete streets, and in particular trends like tactical urbanism, right? At every scale, but all the way up to New York City's Department of Transportation, employing the ideals of tactical urbanism and the aesthetics of tactical urbanism to change, say, Times Square, right, from a big complicated road intersection to a very different pedestrian plaza. Right.
你能，对于那些最近没见过时代广场的人，描述一下时代广场现在有什么吗？当然。所以实际上现在它正变得越来越正式。所以回到你关于它看起来像什么的问题。但它现在是一个大型行人广场。在一条非常狭窄的百老汇大道上允许一点点通行，主要用于送货车辆和自行车。现在只是一个巨大的公共广场，周围环绕着巨大的屏幕和广告以及所有
Can you, some of you who hasn't seen Times Square recently, could you describe what is in Times Square right now? Sure. So actually right now it is becoming increasingly formalized. So kind of back to your question of what it looks like. But it is now a large pedestrian plaza. There is a little bit of access allowed down a very narrow Broadway that's mainly good for delivery vehicles and bikes. And now just an enormous public plaza surrounded by enormous screens and advertising and all
时代广场的其他东西。它确实是从折叠椅和非常简单但城市认可的干预开始的。完全正确。是的，这是交通局做的，但他们采取了这种先行动后问问题的态度，因为他们知道有大量的反对意见，他们只是进去，把它关掉了。我们在旧金山也看到了同样的事情，
the other stuff that Times Square is about. And it really started with like folding chairs and very simple but city-sanctioned intervention. Totally. Yeah. And it was it was the DOT doing it, but they took this act first and asked questions later attitude of like, because they knew there was a ton of opposition and they just went in there, shut it down. And we see the same thing in San Francisco
有“人行道变公园”项目。现在到处都是公园小径的巨大激增，圣何塞、奥克兰，奥克兰自己的拉法姆广场曾短暂地尝试以这种方式进行改造。没错。你能描述一下拉法姆广场的例子吗？当然。
with the pavement to parks program. The huge proliferation of parklets now, everywhere, San Jose, Oakland, Oakland's own Lafam Square was briefly attempted to be transformed in this way. Right. Could you describe the Lafam Square example? Sure.
这是一个三角形的熨斗形状的情况，在奥克兰市中心，电报大道从百老汇大道分叉出来，有一座非常像熨斗的建筑和一块三角形的土地。那里一直有一个公共空间，但有一个想法是他们应该关闭大约一个街区的电报大道，这样百老汇大道就可以笔直延伸，一个新的行人空间就会在那里开放。这在奥克兰实现了，
It's a triangular flat iron sort of situation where there's a very flat iron-esque building in a triangular piece of land where telegraph splits away from Broadway in downtown Oakland. And there has been a public space there, but there was this idea that they ought to shut down about a block of telegraph so that Broadway could continue straight and a new pedestrian space would open up right there. And this was actualized here in Oakland,
由此产生的广场拥有我们正在谈论的这些当代战术公共空间的所有特征。它有很多再生木材的审美。它有很多阿迪朗达克椅或某种折叠椅。这就是你会想象看到作为公共设施拿出来的乒乓球桌，随机出现在某个地方供人弹奏的钢琴。
and the resulting plaza had all the kind of trappings of these contemporary tactical public spaces that we're talking about. It had a lot of reclaimed wood kind of aesthetics. It had a lot of adorandic chairs or folding chairs of some sort. This is where you would imagine to see the ping pong table that's been brought out as a public amenity, the piano that's been, you know, randomly appeared in a place to reveal to play.
这是城市规划和场所营造中日益占主导地位的这种更广泛的创意场所营造趋势的一部分。我认为战术城市主义的精神依然令人难以置信，那就是简单地说，让我们快速且廉价地原型化一些很棒的东西，然后尝试让它变得更永久。但随之而来的那种审美，借鉴了很多DIY的东西，已经变成了这些地方应该看起来的样子。
It's part of this broader trend of creative place making that is increasingly dominant in urban planning and place making. And I think that the spirit of tactile urbanism remains incredible, which is quite simply, let's act quickly and cheaply to prototype something awesome and then try to get it made more permanent. But the kind of aesthetics that have gone along with it that borrow a lot from DIY have become kind of what these places are supposed to look like.
这是创意场所营造这一更广泛趋势的一部分，该趋势在城市规划和场所营造中正变得日益占据主导地位。我认为战术城市主义的精神依然令人惊叹，简单来说，就是让我们快速且低成本地去构建一些很棒的原型，然后再设法使其永久化。但随之而来的那种借鉴了大量DIY风格的美学，已经成为了这些地方本应呈现的样子。
So that parklets now up and down, Valencia and San Francisco have this very similar aesthetic. Most of them have bike parking, Most of them have reclaimed wood. Most of them have some sort of planter kind of a situation. They also basically serve as sidewalk cafes more than as public spaces, or at least they have that potential. And I think that that potential is so realized
因此，现在瓦伦西亚街和旧金山各处的路边停车位改造空间（parklets）有着非常相似的审美。它们大多设有自行车停车位，大多使用回收木材，大多还有某种花坛。它们基本上更像是人行道咖啡馆，而不是公共空间，或者至少它们具有这种潜力。我认为这种潜力已经得到了充分实现，
that I don't even know, like there's one in the sort of gourmet ghetto area, Berkeley, in front of Saul's. I think of that as seating for Saul's. But by definition, cannot be. It is a public space. It's a public space. It's a public space that anyone could sit down at.
以至于我甚至不知道，比如在伯克利的美食区，索尔餐厅（Saul's）门前就有一个。我把它看作是索尔餐厅的座位区。但根据定义，它不能是。它是一个公共空间。它是一个公共空间。它是一个任何人都可以坐下来的公共空间。
But the visual cues of that space are not that anyone could actually sit down in them. That's right. And I think that's one of the problems of the aesthetics of these types of interventions that are done by the city is that they, yeah, they create more public space, but what they define as the proper use of the public is coded into the language of the way the space looks to me anyway. On the other hand, I think that cities are learning a different lesson, which is that the aesthetics of this stuff are increasingly trendy.
但该空间的视觉暗示却并非任何人都可以真正坐下来。没错。我认为这是城市所做的这类干预措施在美学上的问题之一，即它们确实创造了更多的公共空间，但它们对公共空间应如何使用的定义，在我看来已经编码在空间的视觉语言中了。另一方面，我认为城市正在学习一个不同的教训，那就是这些东西的美学正变得越来越时髦。
And as you pointed out, they look like places of consumption, not a true public space, which for better or worse, a true public space is a place that I can roll up with my shopping cart and just sit there, if that's all I've got. And I can throw up protest. And I can, I don't know, do all the other stuff that you're supposed to do in public space. And if they don't look like that, and they serve much more to just catalyze
正如你所指出的，它们看起来像是消费场所，而不是真正的公共空间。无论好坏，真正的公共空间是一个我可以推着购物车直接坐下的地方，如果那是我仅有的东西的话。我可以在那里进行抗议。我还可以，不知道，做所有你应该在公共空间做的事情。如果它们看起来不像那样，而更多地只是起到催化作用，
the economic development or sell overpriced coffee, then that's not the best lesson. I think for how we should be remaking our public spaces. Thank you so much for talking, I really enjoyed. My pleasure. Thanks for having me. Gordon Douglas's book is called The Help Yourself City. Get it, you'll like it. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Chris Baroube and Kurt Colestead, music by Sean Riel.
促进经济发展或销售价格过高的咖啡，那么这就不是我们应该如何改造公共空间的最佳经验。非常感谢你的交谈，我很享受。我的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。戈登·道格拉斯（Gordon Douglas）的书名为《自助城市》（The Help Yourself City）。去买来看看，你会喜欢的。《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）本周由克里斯·巴鲁贝（Chris Baroube）和库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colestead）制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。
Katie Mingle is the senior producer. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Sharif Yusif, Avery Truffleman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KLW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% invisible is a member of radio topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）是高级制作人。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、谢里夫·尤西夫（Sharif Yusif）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街（Radio Row）制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org or on Instagram and Reddit too. But we have links and pictures to the DIY urbanism projects we talked about on this episode at 99pi.org Radio to PO From PRX you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg，或者在Instagram和Reddit上关注我们。我们在99pi.org上提供了本集讨论的DIY城市主义项目的链接和图片。Radiotopia来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。